[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Ben Affleck and
Matt Damon Matt Damon and Ben Affleck
are childhood friend they appeared
together in Chasing Amy and Drew Will
Hunting for which Damon received the
best actor nomination this is their
first Academy Award I just said to Matt
losing would suck and winning would be
really scary and it's really really
scary there's no way we're doing this in
less than 20 seconds we're just really
two young guys who were fortunate enough
to be involved with a lot of great
people because van Sans for a brilliant
Direction Robin Williams who delivers to
Street lines many driver whose
performances brain stealing skarsgarden
was great your brother my brother Casey
who's brilliant in the movies Cole
Hauser my mother and Matt's mother the
most beautiful women here my dad right
over there and um Jack said hi to you
and Chris Moore produce the movie and
Patrick Weitzel the best agent in
Hollywood yeah Patrick and Cuba Gooding
for showing us how to give our eye
acceptance speech and uh and everybody
back in Boston watching us I know we're
forgetting somebody whoever we forgot we
love you and we love you thank you thank
you so much